ah welcome to this video playing god yes
from Russia okay that's a very early c3
signaling his intention here yeah in
London system it is I'm going for a
double en cheto in the style of the reti
opening that's quite often a good anti
dote five blunders piece so that's not a
good idea I can prepare that though the
right moment yeah not not here probably
let's see if I can get in I know I
cannot get this in hmm the plate with
Bishop d3 and Queenie to this way
preventing be five
now maybe I can prepare the five at the
right moment hmm okay jack is looking at
f7 not sure that it's doing much but
he's looking at the square okay i was
thinking night if for him but that's not
playable due to various reasons takes
and Bishop f7 is one of them I can play
five it's not okay let's do that that
was was one idea of my strange looking
Quincy six more getting out of this this
diagonal there yeah night takes was my
idea he cannot take with the night now
due to checkmate okay just checking with
that and now what yeah this moves on
that does make some sense it tries to
play on the Play for the weekend light
squares but I don't think it's a huge
problem
so think this position is about equal
nothing in particular nothing bad
happening here for four black ok I'm
going to be simple about that just take
this take this off get rid of Maya
potentially bad Bishop this the only
thing is that there's this annoying
pressure there on a six that really is
an issue
don't don't see at the moment how to how
to play that she forms kind of a shocker
now he places everything he has on on
Terra on light squares that's kind of
strange mm-hm let's reroute them knight
on f6 doesn't do anything he wants to go
night f1e 325 I guess 55 is all simple
yeah maybe he might argue that that d5
is a more important weakness than F form
right if i go to e6 now he will take it
and then play 93
you have 93 to defy Vincent white quite
annoying them i don't know if i should
go age five here maybe let's try to
weaken this a little bit more and not
sure about age for now that looks quite
weakening so let's do this and now maybe
we age age so that i have night h3
potentially he would play rook age one
though no doubt about that I guess okay
he can play maybe 95 or something but
yes the question is not really let's
retreat he might he might really just
take a 6m and it's possible
yeah but they have rook h3 at the end
that's not a good idea okay so it's that
away from me to try to check I can play
96 by the way right to e6
yeah I should take this opportunity and
trying to get yeah yeah I know trying to
get get Bishop g5 and so here no no
times actually takes then on takes them
quindi six then I don't know I want this
check okay it should be eight Bishop t54
night f form
yeah maybe I'm completely screwing this
up very possible might he might maybe
you can just take heed and now route
cakes it's a passer possible
at least it's quite a mess and not easy
to play night air force is really in
doubt so look T 594 check jim has to go
to f2 then ok but now well I'm checking
the Queen down with temple so how am I
going to play there i can take this one
and b3 maybe yeah okay i'm taking too
much time here this is ok it's not easy
to play i'm going to exchange down but
this is not easy to play going for Queen
a3 b2 here my nidus is really strong
it's very annoying for him my main issue
here is the time actually
objectively speaking I might be in
trouble but this is not easy for easy
for him and now don't want to trade
Queens them
made on g two check check Queen f2 or
queen f4 check check check check luck
yeah just has just totally dead now and
I lose on time stupid ah yeah tiff very
difficult game of course and yeah I
screwed it screwed up timewise ah tricky
help us very tricky and I was very
surprised that he all of a sudden put
everything on light squares it's a very
unconventional strategy but he got this
regrouping and maybe it was okay yeah
objectively speaking I probably were
lost somehow somewhere around here but I
found this and fountains idea
interesting here here Bishop Jake's
takes so Queen d2 refutes my idea okay
yeah that's a pin right yeah Queen d2 is
good they went to F into here but this
also should win still with Queen d2 yeah
because the Queen han dicho would now
mean a pen and this year okay this is a
this is probably good for white but not
easy at all to play and as it went yeah
I got a got a good position at the end
or winning position but um yeah check
can you do 93's completely has made even
check yeah but okay I didn't have any
time I had to head to play quickly
channel maybe there was a checkmate
share a direct made check
okay this is just balls okay Queen f6 is
a draw though okay ads it's a perpetual
cam yeah that's very very hectic with
with the time ah yeah ok well the start
of a session it's never easy thanks for
watching